but it's made big sizes of both but
especially in northern ireland and
northern ireland
with fame come great big murals
on walls uh adrian here you are in i
believe this is in belfast
yes that's right i mean i knew i'd made
it in belfast when i got my own mural
i'm really delighted with that oh yeah
and uh i
think they did a pretty good job as well
right yeah
because uh uh vicky went to visit us and
i think we've got no
really we've got a picture of vicky
showing it it's true respect
here she is oh my god
is that you producing a bubble yes
exactly why would you not do
that thanks
what happened on the way to work that's
what prepares me for the role
and i didn't float up in the line of the
last bubbler of the first bubble or
whatever
those phrases is it true that you and
jeb mercurio
did a kind of a shout out to get some of
these phrases yeah i mean after some of
the q as you might say to people in
belfast you know can you can you write
down a few things that you think ted
my character might say and and they do
that and that was one of the ones of
course that's a very well well-known
belfast phrase oh god yeah yeah
no no graham no seriously my mother's
from belfast she's never said that
you call her tonight hello is that cork
i mean
give her a shout and ask her about
floating up the lagging and a bubble
okay any new ones in in series six
yeah there's uh there's going to be a
couple of new ones there's a really good
one which is highly wished
oh very good you know that i know that
yeah yeah my mother said that a lot
i bet she did yeah i bet she did